il ya d'intéressant dans le cinéma c'est
évidemment c'est banal de le dire mais
c'est le sens du déplacement
c'est à dire la succession des plans et
la chronologie dans longtemps et ça et
il est évident que là on rejoint très
facilement l' architecture qui elle
aussi établi un passage de plans
successifs et une succession dans le
temps
alors là on se retrouve avec le cinéma
surtout avec le cinéma actuel beaucoup
plus qu'avec le cinéma ancien qui dans
le fond faisait beaucoup plus appel à un
les images fixes à des tableaux composés
tandis que maintenant on va vers une fin
cotait facettes de l'espace qui se
rapprochent de nous et de nos problèmes
architecture vous pensez que le problème
du temps à dresde à cnet a directement
directement trait directement
oui on le voit bien regarder ne serait
ce que dans la façon dont danton goutte
une architecture danton la visualise
d'autres l'utilisent que l'on soit
directement concernée puisqu'on habite
cette architecture ou bien qu'on soit
indirectement concerné parce qu'on passe
devant parce que tourner autour il y à
un phénomène essentiel c'est
l'appréhension l'appréhension de cette
architecture la façon dont un spectateur
ou d'autres utilisateurs que nous les
appelons nous prend cette architecture
la saisie est bien le déplacement de
l'individu au tour
c'est ce phénomène essentiel pour nous
il y passe devant il se produit il ay
l'atteindre des mouvements à ce moment
là c'est à ces mouvements qu'on essaye
toujours de répondre on est toujours
passionné quand on étudie une
quand on en arrive à la matérialisation
des formes
on est toujours obnubilés obsédé par
l'histoire de savoir comment vont
s'enchaîner l'aller comment va
s'enchaîner la lecture automatique elle
n'est pas forcément très réfléchie la
lecture de l'architecturé dans la dans
le déplacement malgré ce que vous parlez
de la relecture en termes de cinéma
les deux sont très proches justement par
ce côté espace temps par ce côté
continuum je crois qu'il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de doute là-dessus les
moyens d'expression notre époque que ce
soit le cinéma l'architecturé la
peinture ou la philosophie sont
finalement si on a même axe directeur et
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on se
retrouve et qu'on emploie les mêmes
termes à un poète comme michaud je fais
la même chose quand il fait un poème
actuellement est aussi là ce sens de la
recherche une certaine continuité
ils recherchent des plans à sa manière
dans ses voyages imaginaires c'est très
proche de nous et du film même il ya en
plus précis qui s'établissent comme on
l'a vu lorsque lorsque un cinéaste est
intéressé lui à l' architecture voyez
pas revoir par voie inverse
lorsqu'à signer à se préoccupe des
architectures que l' architecture dans
lesquels évolue son action au lieu
d'être neutre et a déterminé comme ses
trois quarts du temps où au lieu d'être
simplement d'origine le paysage créer
une ambiance pittoresque voyez comme on
fait avec tous les monuments historiques
par exemple quand les personnages sont
autour du coliseum du coup nous sommes
ou quand ils sont autour de l'arc de
triomphe
lorsqu'il est ce sens lorsque le
réalisateur cinématographique se sent
concerné et qu'il essaye de faire
quelque chose avec l' architecture avec
donc le squelette spatiale qu'on lui
donne alors là il ya des rapports plus
précis qui sont dans les rapports
inverse dont je parlais un peu plus
précis très intéressant cinéaste lui
même sens que ce qui représente
larchitecture et s'influencent affluent
sur sa sur sa fan manière de filmer
acheter un terrain difficile dans la
mesure où il n'existe pas l'architecturé
fin juillet la société moderne à le
drame
on peut dire que pratiquement vous avez
vous avez tout de même raison si si on
est un peu dure un peu schématique on
peut dire que depuis le xviiie siècle
il n'existe pas de véritable
architecture à la disposition de l'homme
normal de l'homme des villes de l'homme
de des paysages français habituels pour
trouver déjà une incidence
d'architecturé faudrait se déplacer puis
allez voir un grand barrage ou une chose
comme ça donc voyez dans le cours
habituel des choses pratiquement on est
privé d'architecturé c'est vrai c'est un
tel drame
mais je pense que c'est pas pour tout le
temps et que je crois qu'on est en
pleine gestation et que maintenant on va
passer de l' objet architectural disons
rares à l'urbanisme c'est à dire à un
monde a lieu architecturé et non plus un
objet architectural et je crois que
justement la mesure où on va arriver à
l'urbanisme le côté espace temps de
l'architecturé qui dans le fond être
proche du cinéma
enfin va se développer encore plus parce
que si l'espace temps est un est une
réalité de l'architecturé c'est encore
plus une réalité de l'urbanisme
[Musique]